going to the next one we're on number
seven i think so yeah we're on number
seven which is an actual next category
is the most monkey moment well i might
have a bit of an advantage in this one
this is like saying this best quentin
tarantino movie and they're all quentin
tarantino movies
because there are some very monkey
moments when you fell out okay let's
let's fight it would be like it would be
like the plot twist of the year if you
didn't win this award
well i actually think there's a good
chance that someone else could win this
one
let's look at the nominations right
let's look at the numbers shall we uh
okay
breaking
did you get that on camera i'm surprised
you didn't [ __ ] fall in your arsenal
monkey has good balance i'm surprised it
wasn't the you breaking two cars because
i feel like you breaking two cars is
even more monkey than just breaking a
single bike
right oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh this this was
pretty much what i'm saying this could
be a winner yeah joey's on youtube yeah
this is easily my most monkeys
play the clip joey for five years used a
980 graphics card that was plugged in
cpu graphics
i completely forgot about that yeah that
is pretty much don't worry audience
i properly plugged it in now i i plugged
it in
connor literally held his hand and was
like joey do this this is where you plug
it in
i was like okay father me skipping cups
i stand by this let's play this clip i
don't know what happened to me in the
womb but like i
i can't pay attention to story and games
the moment story comes on any video game
i'm like where's the skip button where
is it
really it's true it's true as nikki
jakey says you have that goopy goblin
game
man i do i can't pay attention to
cutscenes it's it's just what it is
text and dialogue and listening reading
you know
there's no
was like can you just like gameplay a
few books for the thumbnail i was like i
don't know any books
and i was like he's like you don't well
i like monk i was like no i don't have
any books i don't really get
any books yeah connor's house and my
house is the literal opposite
not even like manga volumes i own one
single manga book
and that's just that's the exact same
that's for sure yeah
that's that book on the coffee table i
literally don't own any i don't read
books like straight up
this is what it is i admit that i love
you i have a feeling that
you know because uh here there's three
connor moments this yeah the vote could
be split between three good goodness i'm
giving joey the edge of being the most
monkey brain maybe
yeah yeah yeah also another one
of ladybird being a monkey baby is in
like and i see
and i say this in the nicest way
possible is one of the hardest people to
work with
oh [ __ ] to this day ladybird is the only
guest that has
like done permanent damage to our sets
he dented our [ __ ]
play button and i remember afterwards he
still like was moving around so much and
it was just like
giving me so much anxiety whenever i see
him move back and forth yeah right
you can tell he was like a proper pro
wrestler he was probably manhandling
that hike
that man just throws his massive body
weight around yeah because
because when we told him before the
podcast started that like you need to
have this mic
up to your face he was like got it just
[ __ ] grabbed it like this and was
like okay so
uh we normally have to turn guest's
microphone up yeah we're not used to it
but we actually have to turn his down
which is a first and i think it'll be a
last honestly yeah i had a better handle
of that microphone to do with my life
like it was like it was impressive
honestly all right and then this last
one is an absolute classic trash taste
moment oh yeah
sometimes if i'm like real angry some
days or i wake up and i'm upset i'll
just go in the mirror
i'll be like come on
i still do that i still do that
sometimes you've got to do it my
neighbors probably don't appreciate it
yeah absolutely frankly they're probably
in a war yeah so who cares
exactly it's just like it's it's
sometimes i just hear some lines from
you and it's
your like brain is just like literally
that monkey picture that's just like
neuron activation
right that is that is like sometimes
when i see some of the stuff you do it's
just that literal picture yeah
all right so which one do you think is
going to win guys i have
a feeling it's going to be one of
conor's but i secretly hope
with the gpu honestly on paper it's the
gpu is the most monkey
right out of every one of these single
moments
it's the gpu one i think i am body
monkey yeah the dumbest moment yeah
the standout one yeah in my opinion yeah
it's the juxtaposition and again like i
said i think because people who might
think
i'm the most monkey they might spread
their votes out yeah i think there's a
chance
because because these ones are just like
monkey moments but i think like you
literally regret an evolution when you
did this yeah
like and i i hear guts theme playing
yeah that opened up your pieces
yeah this is this is like momentary
monkey this is five years monkey
all right all right i have the winner
right here though let's find out trash
chase the water will most monkey moment
goes to
joey's on you let's go
you know what i ain't even mad i ain't
even mad the upsets
the absolutely upset fantastic great
moves wow
how what was this a landslide not really
31.2 percent
okay what came last well what came
next yeah okay what came next was conor
skipping cutscenes
conor skipping cutscenes and then okay i
think last was ladybird
oh yeah yeah my theory was right yeah
yeah yeah
votes was spread out yeah yeah yeah and
then ladybird is just like that was just
one monkey moment out of a two and a
half hour monkey yeah
i'm glad you won that one i'll take the
dog i'll take the dolphin i'm really
happy you won that one i'm glad you won
that one as well this is the moment
this is the most honorable dishonorable
mention i've ever got i mean it was just
like i'd say it's an upset but it was
also well deserved well deserved
well deserved well done me give myself